each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
Sarah as rob said i'm jan and this is
work done with another student of mine
or zanz you know student another student
at Stanford with me residency no sassy
PhD student and what it is is it's a
study looking at interruptions on
software teams so to give you kind of a
broad or frame for that for most of us
who are work in collaborative knowledge
work or work with other people
interruptions are pretty much a fact of
life anyone working collaboratively has
some need to coordinate action or share
information with other people and what
that means is that we're going to have
to interrupt each other at some point in
order to get that done the study i'm
going to talk about today takes a really
in-depth look at interruption occurrence
and incidents on to software development
teams one that works almost exclusively
in pairs due to their use of the XP
extreme programming methodology and one
where the programmers work in the more
traditional way working alone and we're
it's pretty in-depth so i'm sure by the
end you're gonna be really sick of
interruptions and how they occur but
you'll bear with me hopefully it'll be
worth it so a really really reef review
of excellent work on the field there's a
couple studies out there that look at
knowledge work that look at
interruptions there's a lot of work on
interruptions and they've kind of
established that collaborative work is
complex and fragmented so we can't think
of it as a linear activity you just do
your task done move on to the next
people switch tasks a lot people move on
between different tasks interruptions or
a crucial part of knowledge work that
you need that to get information from
other people on the team but a lot of
studies have established that there
actually stressful for workers so you'll
have people reporting high levels of
stress frustration on reduced
productivity and anxiety because of the
level of introduction that they
experienced in the course of work and
one thing these studies all really look
at and one way that my studies will our
study is a little bit different is that
they've all looked at workers working
alone and interrupted while engaging in
independent work so that way that's
something really different here is that
we're looking at both people working
alone
working by themselves and people that
are working in pairs which no one's ever
really taking a deep Bukit so in terms
of framing the study the research
questions that we had when we went into
looking at this slice of a larger
ethnographic study is one how do you
interruptions affect knowledge workers
that are configured in pairs rather than
working individually and what difference
does that make it's an opportunity for
us to take a look at what pair
programming works it looks like in the
real world institue and how can this
understanding of interruptions in paired
work inform the design of work tools so
not only work tools to support paired
work but also how's it going to come
back and change the way that solo
developers work how can we build things
that will better support so developers
using what we've learned about paired
work and interruptions so that's the
goal it's kind of a goal that we went in
so tell you a little bit about where we
looked a research site is to product
development teams at the same mid-sized
startup company in Silicon Valley it's
really small a company team pair so we
did ethnographic observations there from
team pair we were there from may to
august of 2005 I'm team solo we were
there from august to december of 2004 we
actually had three more months with team
pair but that data wasn't included here
for regional talked about in a second we
followed both teams through planning
design implication implementation and
product release so a complete product
cycle to lessen the chance that what we
were seeing is behavior associated with
just a particular phase of the project
so we saw the whole thing to tell you a
bit about each team's team pair did pair
programming again as a part of extreme
programming XP they worked in a large
open bullpen like space with visual and
aural access to their teammates and I'll
show you a picture of that I'm in a
second to get a sense of that because
people haven't worked in this
environment these programmers really
frequently consulted with each other
through face-to-face communication
that's kind of their primary means of
talking to each other was walking over
and starting a conversation they had
very limited email use primarily to talk
to people outside of the team within the
same company because the rest of the
company's email wat and these telephone
but almost exclusively for personal
calls so people would call them they'd
answer that but not
talking to other members of the team
mostly because everyone was always in
the same space day to day so they didn't
have a need for those technologies so
really virtually all the work on this
team was done on site so there's no
working from home there's no remote work
here everyone comes to the office at the
same time every day works in the same
place and then they leave at the end of
the day so here's kind of a photo of
that it's not a great photo that space
you can see it's a small team I can get
their height during observations they
had 12 people but you see what 1 2 3 4 5
and I sometimes they had a six stations
set up there with two monitors each each
of those are onto a shared computer
showing had two keyboards and two mice
that they could operate not at the same
time but they can alternate use and that
was very fluid they could just jump in
any time to go ahead and take that other
keyboard from someone and you can see
they can see everyone and they're
sitting close enough to each other that
they can pretty much hear everything
that's going on okay team solo there's
no picture for them because they look
like kind of your typical software
development setup they work in
individual cubicles clustered together
so if everyone on the same team has
cubicles in the same area of the office
for communication they use a much wider
range of technologies or mechanisms face
to face communication for when people
were in the office they would walk over
and say you know ask a question they use
email a lot and they used what's called
Lily it's a computer mediated
communication tool coming out of rpi or
an insulator polytechnic institute and
what it is it's kind of a big text based
chat room and tell from the texts so
it's kind of a big they have windows
open you can log in you can subscribe to
different chat lines which they had
organized by for instance functional
groups in the company your work team
there's one called water cooler for you
know all sorts of random talk some were
more topical in nature and what that was
was just a big window that they kept
open on their machines and as people
talk to these line sent messages to
these lines it would scroll up on that
screen the also had to be the ability to
send personal messages to each other on
Lily the team was avid Lily users usage
was pretty high among the company I'd
say almost everyone used it except the
XP team who did not
use it at all thirteen parent who did
not use it all but these guys were
actually pretty hardcore about it almost
all the team members logged in whenever
they were at work for sure so that they
could be available via Lily to everyone
else on the team but like most people
I'd say you know about forty percent of
them actually we're on Lily anytime they
were in front of a networked computer so
they would log on first thing in the
morning when they woke up before they
got to work they would log on at work
they would go home from work they would
walk on again and they would log off
right before they went back to sleep
they'd be there on weekends so they were
almost successful any time they were
near a computer they were on Lily so
that's kind of the extent to which
Lily's was pervasive in this team for
telephones they use that to Colin to
meetings otherwise throughout the day it
was primarily for personal use didn't
really call each other to talk to each
other and the team members on this team
it was actually partially geographically
distributed they had one or two members
that were in different parts of the
country kind of varied depending on what
phase the project they were in and the
team members regularly worked from home
part of that is because they had these
technologies that made it possible for
them to do that because of their partial
distribution so usually one or two days
a week they just went home and worked
from home all day okay methodology we
did weekly visits sometimes bi-weekly
each time we spent three to five hours
with the developers just like a luxury
of academia man we SAT behind the
developer or the pair of developers and
we took really extensive notes of their
actions and the context in which these
actions occurs to whatever else that was
going on around them that affected what
they were doing we brought along an
audio recorder to capture dialogue and
sounds although not for the first three
months which is why we can't use that
data that was transcribed integrated
with our notes we generated very
detailed transcripts of what was going
on in each one they reigned about 40
pages each so it's just like a ton of
stuff from each one of these visits and
for this particular study what I then
did was go through each one of those
transcripts and identified interruption
instances talk a little bit about what
that is next we recorded for each of
these interruption instances information
such as how long information
interruption occur took how did occur
who started it why did it start and then
we tried to categorize those
interruptions based on these
characteristics to draw some more
general statements about them so an
interruption instance we defined as any
instance in which the workers turned
away from their primary work task either
on their own or in reaction to the
actions of others and the way we
establish what their primary work task
was was that each day when we started an
interruption we just asked we said
what's what are you working on today and
they would tell us what they thought was
kind of their main goal name task and if
that ended and they changed to a new
task they usually told us they said okay
now I'm going to work on X and so that's
what we use in our analysis as prime
work tasks when they started working on
something else they didn't tell us then
we'd say okay well this is a secondary
task this isn't really your your primary
goal for today and we had about 40 hours
of useable observation data cold from
all those observations about 22 of them
for 22 hours on team pair 18 hours in
team solo I'm here during that we saw
242 interruptions 138 of them run team
pair and 104 the momentum solos to
roughly equivalent numbers on the two
what we did was we do in a taxonomy by
two researchers at the University of
Texas called jet and George that
categorized interruptions as either
intrusions distractions or breaks and
then we also looked at as whether they
were self or externally initiated and so
I'll talk a little bit about each of
those in turn so this is just a framing
for what I'm going to talk about next we
found that the interruptions differed
across the two teams by length contact
content type and time of occurrence the
programmers on the two teams differed in
strategies and practice when they were
the interrupter the person who goes to
interrupt the other programmer versus
the interrupt e the person who's being
interrupted and that self isn't
self-initiated interruptions differed
strongly across teams in that last point
I think is particularly interesting so
i'll get to that they don't talk about
why so here's kind of the numbers
interruption length the interruptions on
team pair were consistently shorter than
team solo regardless of the type and
source
this isn't a great table so I tried to
put some color in there to make it a lot
easier nurse dancer but you see it's
routine pair are total observation time
21 hours and 41 minutes team solo 18
hours and 29 minutes the average length
of an introduction on the pair team was
one minute and 55 seconds it's across
138 of them Tim still two minutes and 45
seconds that's across 104 of them so you
see there about 50 seconds difference
between the two categories to break that
down a little again team pairs are
before in every category self-initiated
is a huge one it's two minutes and 16
seconds on team pair across 50
interruptions three minutes and 38
seconds on Team solos about an hour and
15 or pinner a minute and 15 seconds
difference in that time they certainly
initiated I could go down but uh
basically and every single one the pairs
are much shorter and then the notable
ones are ranging between 30 seconds to
about a minute and a half and then the
break self-initiated interruptions in
the break so the ones where you see that
big difference between the two teams and
I'll talk a little bit about why that is
so like structurally and socially okay
Sarah then on so wet how did we
categorize each one these are the
definitions from the jet indoors paper
intrusion they defines be an unexpected
encounter initiated by another person
that interrupts the flow and continuity
of Ninja Turtles work and brings that
work to a temporary halt so whenever
someone else some external thing stops
you usually another person okay so team
pairs and children here's kind of a
sample transcript from one of them to
intrusions introduced or initiated by
their team members on this team were
primarily functional in nature so
someone coming in to ask you information
that they need for a task like hello I
had to obfuscate the tech stuff in this
sample for the company to let me use it
so which is why it might not make too
much sense as you're reading through it
I tried to like make it a little more
generic but this is kind of a classic
intrusion what's happening here is that
Benden Carlos is a pair that's working
together and Dana is another developer
working in a different pair and she's
just going to turn an ask them a
question they don't even leave their
seats often to do this so they're just
sitting around and they say hey did you
guys stop with the locks this is a task
that they've been working on before they
start discussing it they pick how to
pick up on what they were doing before
and in the middle of this other team
members will frequently join in because
they're in the small room conversations
going across people and so here we see
Andy and Eric two other developers who
weren't a part of the original
interruption just come in and join the
discussion as it's going on that
happened to quite a lot so they vary
greatly in both length and scope terms
of who's involved with the interruptions
some of the intrusions on this team were
purely social in nature but those are
really short and a little rarer social
interruptions tended to be two or three
line conversations here someone will
make a joke no laughs and then they'll
go right back to work or often what
happened as will start having a social
conversation and someone go guys we got
to get back to work and so those tended
to be shortly kind of clamped down on
that across the team and then finally
the largest or the second largest source
of intrusions on this team was probably
their cell phones because they all
everyone had cell phones and they got
calls throughout the day they would
almost always answer them and then they
leave the work area in order to answer
the phone have that conversation then
come back so team solos intrusions
looked very different and this is
actually a really long example that cuts
across two pages all walk through it the
intrusions tended to be a mix of both
functional and social so in here this
one will see as well come in and they're
making jokes they're teasing so frozen
grant frozen Henry show up at Grant's
cubicle so grant is the developer I'm
observing during this during this
session and they come up and he's handed
out these like gag memo pads that he's
gotten from a conference and they have
their like IP protocol pads and so each
of the pad has like fields for each of
the IP protocol fields you know they're
teasing him about it making jokes is
very you know social stuff and at some
point at the very bottom through this
conversation and this isn't edited
actually Henry just says this he just
changes right into a question about work
he says hey should I check in the code
to work with the scanning stuff and so
what's going to happen is that launched
as a conversation about the release that
they're going to do on Wednesday right
and talking about their product on
different platforms and whether it's you
know what the status is right now and
then drawn in by the sound of this
conversation another developer pairs in
it and she shows up at the cubicle
entrance and that immediately turns the
conversation back to social she's giving
some office gossip in this case what
happened is she bought a caramel tart
but dropped it on the ground and then
she put it in the kitchenette anyway and
she sent a message to everyone on Lilly
the don't eat the targets on the ground
but the Eckstein pears not on Lilly so
they didn't know so she comes in and
sees them in there receiving his heart
and so she comes over to tell about that
so it's just like so so again here you
see this big mix of social and
functional there longer they tend to be
meandering they involve some form of
movement like people usually go to
another person's cubicle and talk to
them for a little while and then okay
and then other than that there are other
again there are other big source of
intrusions or phone calls personal phone
calls that they receive throughout the
day they usually stay in their workspace
when they answer those calls which is a
little odd because even though they're
in their cubicles you can hear
conversation very clearly across the
cubicles but for some reason they don't
seem to really think about that they
still went to the phones right and the
cubicles but that's kind of a the look
of intrusions on these two teams so
distractions Jack and George describe
this is a psychological reaction
triggered by external stimuli or
secondary activities that interrupts
focus concentration on a primary task so
often noises in the environment or
something visual in the environment and
the way we detected these in our
observations is when they pause we
usually noted that when we were watching
them and often they would reorient
towards the similar they would turn
their heads towards the source of the
sound and one second or they'd make a
comment about that you know what's that
noise that's really annoying yes people
were talking on the phone where other
were these people having
so that they would not get distracted at
money no that was rare they actually
just listened you could talk because
they would usually make comments about
it later like at lunch they'd be like Oh
heard you talking about X sorry but they
still kept it kept going now verily I I
saw a couple developers with headphones
in their cubes but I never saw them use
it so I think they had them with the
intent to use so distractions on team
pair because they're in the middle of
this environment that has so much cross
conversation that peripheral
conversation is a huge source of
distractions for them you saw that
already in the intrusion where you saw
two other developers get distracted and
drawn to the conversation most of them
are faster quicker incidences like here
Levi is talking to Kevin another
developer and they're just saying
talking about a bug in the application
they said when the dialog boxes is too
small so its crop in the error messes it
shows up and Eric Nathan who are working
next to them just stop and listen and
then start making comments about it in
this case it doesn't stick it's really
fast and so you know ten seconds later
he turns back to his work Nathan listens
for a little bit longer but that's kind
of the length of their distractions on
that team but that happened quite a lot
because of the noisy environment that
they were in in general they filtered
out conversation pretty well where they
kept those distractions at a minimum
what really bugged him was a regular
noise thank you come and you start
rustling papers or like rappers they get
really annoyed at you and they sir look
at me until you stop which makes sense
right you learn to work in this work
environment and you get it used to the
constant buzz of conversation but if
there's something in regular that's
really disruptive to their thinking and
their work and then the other thing is
that physical objects in the work
environment or source of distraction
this is not like a huge inside in fact
they made use of this quite a lot they
had several visual displays in that
shared work area but deliberately would
they had a bill monitor running that
showed the status of all their for
automated builds that ran on different
systems under different configurations
and it would flash red or green
depending on the status of the build and
that was deliberate to draw people's
attention to problems with their process
so in this case Eric sees the bill
monitor flashing and says hey is anyone
fixing nipple yes as observers how often
were you
to them we excluded from here any time
that we were an obvious source of
distraction but actually in the pair's
section not really because they're
already in this room they're already
talking to each other so there's very
little that we really need to do as
observers we're just there capturing
what they do we didn't actually have to
ask that many questions because you
could hear what they were talking about
and what they were thinking about in
that environment so most time we just
SAT behind rather quietly but yeah any
time we did do that there we took that
out of set so that's not in here the
silicide were probably a little bit more
intrusive because they're not used to
having someone sitting to keep with them
but the way we kind of got around that
is that we spent two or three sessions
with each developer and so usually they
kind of got used to us by Oh after a
while people got pretty good at ignoring
us when they really needed to do work
because we encourage them with like you
know for in your way just ignore us and
so like for instance we notice there's a
difference the first time you sit with
the developer they're like start only on
task the whole time you know you ain't
never goof off but like my time 3
they're like watching videos and they're
like hey check out this like comic with
someone sent me so it's a little more
representative I think of what's going
on hey so finally breaks I talked about
oh yeah so team solo the distractions
are similar its conversation irregular
noises one thing that really differs on
that team is that the lily chat window
is a big source of distractions for
there whenever chat activity starts to
slow up you see people stop and look at
that to read usually that's a really
quick check to see if there's anything
they need to look at or pay attention to
and then they go back to work although
sometimes it triggers them into a longer
more extended interruption and we'll
talk about that and their self-initiated
interruptions yeah your reason why
um the two of them are well you're
working in pairs and you're focused on
your task and so they just didn't really
feel a need to him and they didn't even
check their email throughout the day
which was actually kind of frustrating
for the rest of the company because they
would try to send out like announcements
like I mean I saw I can sense where they
sent out this announcement that was like
someone's blocked me in right since
parked in double parked and they're
blocking someone who needs to leave an
aperitif just never ever got the message
eventually we had to like walk into the
pair cute area and say like who's you
know who's got like a black honda civic
because it's blocking around so they
just I mean they were very focused on
what they were doing and they just
didn't feel this need to to check their
email or even do yeah scratches that
they got from email they got employee
um II different there were different
types because Lily tended to be more
social right email you tend to some
people email work-related email that's
like hey there's a bug here can you look
at it or I just fix this you know or a
lot of times it was automatic
notifications so they'd get check-in
nails and it's like Oh someone's checked
in a bunch of code I should look it over
Lily you got a whole gamut like people
would be like I just thought Lord of the
Rings this weekend it was awesome you
know versus or you know support really
needs us to answer this question about X
so different in the sense that the
content was different but mode of
delivery not not so much other than Lily
was always open they had to easily
explicitly they didn't keep their emails
out they would go and check email some
of them did some of them did not they
tried regularly enough that it didn't
seem to make much of a difference yeah I
wonder about the classification of the
build monitor as a distraction doing
continuous integration and the build
breaks that one would think that that
was part of the core task yeah that in
the frame of how we're looking at
interruptions right in terms of how they
come to the person being interrupted but
it's not intrusion because it's not
someone coming to you it's not a break
because you're not stopping it's
something in the environment draws your
attention so in that sense it's
categorized you're probably thinking of
is in the sense of distraction has that
overtone of being something that's not
important right where's is the bill
monitor is actually quite important for
them to monitor and so we're not using
distractions in that sounds for using
distractions in the sense that it just
draws your attention so any other
questions sounds like you don't
being a positive or a negative yeah any
of these yeah because actually even the
the other classifications have the
potential to be valuable mm-hmm to the
individuals of these games they just
stopped you from working on the flow
they're just descriptive terms that's
why I give a definition each time one of
you we're sort of mutualism it's good to
get any nice underhanded yet with the
teams working on similar applications um
and if so what have I occasions were
there one of them was working on a user
facing java application that integrated
the company's back end products to be
managed i'm kind of say it without
giving away too much information about
it but it was pretty complicated they
had to work pretty closely with the
server side stuff that was done on unix
linux and so so in some sense they were
pretty closely tied together although
they did a lot more UI stuff that's team
pair and they're also I mean they're not
meant for like John Doe user it's meant
for administrators who are configuring
networks and need pretty detailed
configuration options and so it's not
like you know you're not making things
for your sister or your mom or you know
the general public team solo was built a
whole set of different like server stuff
you know that they that people could use
to do network configuration so different
languages different kind of different
platforms there was some overlap there
but they're reasonably tightly tied in
terms of what they had to know yeah
as far as the programmers go was there
for high-level programmers on 11 team
first the other um team solo had well
they both had a couple people that were
really considered the Guru's like you'd
ask anyone they'd be like that guy you
know he knows everything about the
project he's the expert he's they are we
go to and a bunch of new people so they
both had a spread they were configured a
little bit differently but in terms of
the range of expertise you had on the
two sides i would say teams so those
programmers had been with the company
longer and so they had more expertise
with that product but they also had new
programmers who had just been there for
you know six to ten months team pair was
a newer project it had only been think
two years old at that point versus the
solo I mean day worked out as a startup
company so they have like five products
and everyone works on everything on the
silicide on the parricide they had been
brought in specifically to do this one
project but that integrated across all
the different solo projects so they were
newer I would say in terms of time like
programming work experience probably a
few average amount is roughly equal
actually how about it never did that guy
get eaten so any other questions okay
did I talk about teen solos distractions
I think it did right okay you don't you
didn't it I don't think you told us what
teams solos development process was team
pair was using an extreme programming
Asia process what about team solo
waterfall ish not strict okay um but
basically I mean they say all sorts of
things that there were my chin and they
were like over kind of like scrum and it
was like no you're not like if they do
anything that's like scrum really did
you have a morning meeting that's it I
was like do that let's grow so is you
had to pick it out yourself
okay so oh yeah you go back to the side
of them I'm curious about the number of
self interruptions only 40 care okay so
team here actually has more for short
but they're shorter yeah and we'll talk
a little bit I mean to have a question
right now all right so we see next to
your leg watch that video on youtube
mm-hmm but then you said I'm also
wondering how having observed there by
seven at I watched several Star Trek
videos so I I don't know I was like this
girl I didn't tell my niece es stuff and
you know I just nice and yet i would
still guide into the leonard nimoy bilbo
baggins video fester I think that is how
self aware there are you assuming that
because there's more because i read that
is I see more interruptions on
self initiated
whatever they do
here
well you know what I'm about to walk
through breaks so why don't we do that
and if you still have a question you're
talking about Lily email big big
distractions for Team soul however the
external initial initiated there's
distraction higher no no those are all
externally initiated interruptions okay
so that includes people coming over
tactical the nature of their
interruptions yeah you can see that in
the numbers right they have 94
intrusions versus so that's why
confusing hear it this is all the
interruptions split into three
categories and this is all the
interruptions split into two categories
sorry I told you was bad team or
suggestions would be great and how to
format this one better okay so here's
some suggestion and I would be
interesting to see approximately how
many distractions per hour on that table
but and you might actually I mean are
all intrusions externally let's see
politicians distractions and
as all your brakes would-be self
initiated all your intrusions would be
externally initiated what about
distraction they're kind of in between
so I mean what's thing is use these
categories analytically but when you
actually like the data things are really
messy great this is what happens anytime
you do ethnographic work because you
have a bunch of stuff that's like really
clearly an intrusion really clearly
distraction then you have a bunch of
stuff that's like halfway in between
it's like what do you do for one when
you to further and so what we did was
try to very consistently go through and
make those decisions about sorting each
one's but if you actually look at the
data right it's not clearly in three
buckets it's more continuum across each
other I'm seeing there's a higher count
of intrusions than there are extremely
initially initiated and tough as a
self-initiated intrusion a
self-initiated intrusion any and
externally initiated interruptions and
there's 94 intrusions
well it's just apprenticed at the nature
of data um I can't think of it offhand
so why don't we wait and if you I'll try
to either come up with somebody and talk
or you can send me email so we can move
on okay two breaks we had planned or
spontaneous recesses from work on a task
that interrupts the task flow or
continuity so pretty straightforward
definition break when people stop
working on team pairs these Braves are
usually personal task or errands they
have to leave go to the doctor they'll
take mental breaks we'll go get a cup of
coffee from the kitchenette and they
usually involve a physical absence from
the workspace in these cases will walk
out of the work area to do whatever it
is and then come back there in the
workspace in taking a break this was
really rare they're usually checking
email really fast and I think maybe only
saw three instance of this across the
entire observation period we're surfing
the web in the morning before things
have kind of started but pretty so you
kept these pretty quick for solo the
brakes and I'm going to talk a little
bit about more about the center
self-initiated interruptions but what
the brakes seem to do is they kind of a
drew lots of people in and they tend to
spawn other types of interruptions so
here's our leonard nimoy bilbo baggins
video what's happening is someone's just
in the middle of working he stops to
read Lily he just stops in his task to
check Lily because he see something on
there and then she's reading it he sees
it's a link to a video on the web and he
decides to open it and he types it into
a web browser it starts to play well you
can hear things across these cubicles
and so the sound of the music draws in
froze and then later grant to is cubicle
to start watching this video with him
and then by the end grunts like oh wait
you know here's this other hilarious
video that I heard of you know let's
watch that one and so you can start to
see why these things are getting much
longer and that difference between the
two team um to talk a little bit about
interrupter strategies and interrupting
strategies here interrupter strategies
this is what you do when you're going to
go interrupt someone the people on team
pair really tried to take advantage of
the fact that they could see everyone to
be good about interruptions so they
would try to watch you saw people
scanning the
room to look for lolz and conversation
when they can make an announcement or if
they're interrupting a particular person
they would wait for that person's
conversation to die down before going
over to ask a question in some ways
that's kind of good and bad because they
used a really rough metric right they
basically used when conversation ends so
conversation was taken as a sign of
active engagement and whatever task
you're doing silence is taken as a good
time to interrupt but often for these
programmers silence and if they had made
the decision on what to do when
returning to implement it now and that's
when people would come in and ask a
question so they tried to use this
information it's kind of questionable
whether they use that really well
whether that really was a net benefit
for them and ultimately even when they
tried to be really accommodating about
this they were kind of fundamentally
limited by this need for timely
information so you can only wait so long
even if you are watching someone you can
see them working really hard some point
you need that information to move on in
your task so you're just going to go
ahead and ask anyway so that's something
that's interesting here is because a lot
of the systems that we see it's built to
support interruption handling talk about
giving contextual information the person
who's going to interrupt but here it's
like well they have some form of
contextual information and they're not
using it very well because they need
that information in the end about jira
yes if you had a potential interrupter
who had multiple sources of information
did you see them ranking based on the
arm
people my colleague really as the Guru
seems to be busy so maybe I'll ask
somebody who's not as good or big a look
they did eventually but it had to be a
pretty sustained interruption like it
was that the head the boss right they
would wait for him because they didn't
want to national interrupt him but like
everyone else on the team was pretty
much interruptible wherever it was and
the other thing is on the team so as you
see this is that they didn't have that
visual information so they would just
when they walked over to someone's
else's cube they just show up but they
have no idea what that guy's doing and
lore girl and they'll walk in and just
ask their question and even regardless
of whether that person is hard at work
or not they'll just ask the question
because they've already walked all the
way over here right so the cost of them
was so high that's like well I'm just
going to go ahead and interrupt you they
had actually a little bit better
information they had Lily which tells
you when someone's online it tells you
when their idle and it lets you see when
they've posted information to the chat
channels but they honestly didn't
actually use that as an information
source in order to consider interrupter
availability they only used it when
after they walked over and someone
wasn't there right to see how long it
was that they might get an information
leak as you've been gone ten minutes or
hasn't only been gone for 30 seconds
what am I likely to see that so that was
really interesting because they have
this source of information that can give
them information about what they're
doing and they don't didn't use it they
just go over so that I found yeah
wait for the break not very long maybe
five minutes tops they just won't watch
watch and then they usually because I'm
the other thing was often if two people
were simply not working because they
needed that information and they felt it
was more important to interrupt them to
wait interrupt T strategies i'm in team
pair because you're in this open room
you don't have very much control over
and choose and timing right people come
you know people call you over and you
have to respond there right there
they're physically in the room it's hard
to defer that when they're right there
so you have to respond pretty
immediately but they had a lot more
control over the duration and how to end
that interruption so what they could do
is one they would usually have one
member of the pair continue to work
through that interruption to instead of
having the interrupter walk over to the
side of me interrupt Eon team pair the
interrupted person walked over to the
interrupters because they're in Paris
you walk over to the other two people
you look at their computer to help them
resolve their issue what this means is
that they can shut down that
interruption pretty easily like when
they feel like they need to get back to
work they just leave and there's not a
lot that the other guys can do about it
you know other than late trying to call
you over again and what they can do is
they can watch what their pair is doing
so if their pair partners just sitting
there spinning their wheels you'd see
them look over see their pair partner
and say you know here's all I can tell
you look at this you know ask me again
if he knew more information damn they're
out of there they go back to work I'm
team so you don't see that because
people come to your cubicle what you do
see is people desperately trying to work
through interruptions that are going on
around them all they can do is try and
it had a signal that they're done you
know they'd like you to leave so that
they can do work and software developers
that doesn't often take on the first
couple tries especially when a lot of
people are there so they'll be talking
at each other and you'll see the person
who originally had the interruption like
valiantly attempting to like do their
task in the middle of all this and
eventually kind of people will get that
idea and start to leave but it's it's a
really different they just don't have
control over that it's the interrupter
who decides when to go back to their
cubicle when they're then they're done I
mean they would usually get more and
more blunt ever timely people like well
I'd like to work now when you're really
great if I could work what they did do
is they tried to minimize intrusions by
just simply limiting their
ability so what they did was they would
work from home and one of the reasons
they did then we heard several
developers site was that they could get
work done people weren't always coming
in to ask some questions because when
they're working from home all those
questions come in through lily and since
it's chat and you know it's asynchronous
you can let that sit for a little while
before you have to respond to them and
you can wait you know it respond to a
whole bunch of things in one session so
you have more control over when you do
that response yes no I didn't want to go
there I but I did I could see them
whenever they talked on Lily when I was
observing the other programmers so I
mean that's one of the reasons I could
tell that for instance when I was
observing people they weren't
necessarily whether or not they were
kind of with her to behavior patterns
like there's this one developer I think
he's called firs here where I was with
him the first time and he just worked
straight the whole time but every time I
was observing someone else he was like
on Lily every like 10 minutes right like
always a message on there and i was like
huh how are you doing i was there yeah
at home it was there any verification on
for you you tell that they actually did
get more work done at home or even more
like know what I will say is that they
worked all the time kind of like they
probably did less concentrated work at
work but then at like 9pm on a Friday
night you could get them to answer
questions and look into bugs so they
were doing like dispersed spurts of work
all over the place given their yeah
given their activity on Lily I would
guess that they were not nearly as
focused at home as they'd like to think
they were but I did not go to someone's
house to verify that it's it it's
actually really hard to get people what
you do that we tried it for another
study yeah 14 so how did one developer
know whether another one was in the
office or what so they had a morning
meeting every morning both teams did and
that was one way like you knew who was
in because they were physically there
and you knew who called in so right away
every morning they knew who was going to
be in the office and who wasn't so yeah
they also saw attached messages from
Lily it's called whenever someone logs
on there's a message about it and
usually what they were really good about
doing was keeping information about that
it has a little blurb that you can send
people would say like coming to work you
know or at work now and so that was also
a way they were actually pretty good at
tracking when people were around yeah so
in the team air case since the nobody
has to move home it seems like there's
an interrupt key strategy where you can
say hang on wait wait do two minutes to
finish this
yeah you see a lot of it we saw it every
once in a while but again it's hard to
do that when you can tell they're not
doing anything because they need your
information so everyone's for all you
did see someone really say like no I
gotta finish this first but it was
really really fast because those guys
are just spinning their wheels and
sending around and the whole team can
see that they can see that you're
holding up that that other pair so any
inhale yes what did you see is the cost
of the context resumption once the
interruption was over how long did it
take before these people uh she got back
to work um I'll talk a little well I
didn't have since I don't have video
data it's a little hard for me to see
that on the solo side unless they say
something when they start work like it's
you know when do you turn your head to
start looking at the task again so I
didn't have that precise measurement and
I'm kind of bummed about it because that
was something that was pretty interested
in looking at after I started getting
into interruption behavior so I don't
actually have that I do have some more
rougher qualitative stuff and they're on
the next two slides so talking about
self in initiating interruptions so on
team pair the brakes are taken whenever
developer sees fit slightly more between
task or when they have a walnut ass like
they're waiting for a build or something
but really not too much they'll just
kind of take it whenever and it can be
really abrupt this is something that
surprised me although I don't have
anything really to follow up on it for
like Dana and Eric here they're they're
talking they're in the middle of
designing this class or figuring out
where to go and then he'll just get up
and walk out you know two seconds after
the last statement and so it's very
abrupt but I mean one reason that might
be okay is because those brakes are so
short that they almost always come back
quickly enough that it's not considered
like really rude or or bad for them to
do that I'm almost always one thing you
see is the developer continues working
as a break occurs and so that sounds it
looks a little weird when you watch it
because for instance when they're
waiting for a bill sometimes these build
takes between you know three to five
minutes or even longer depending on what
they're doing and one guy will just sit
there in front of the computer watching
it waiting for the precise moment for it
to finish until you can check in and
this is something you never see on the
solo side they don't always do something
else and well I'll show you here is that
sort of
and once it gets you in trouble but it
leads to these longer breaks these
longer interruption sessions so on the
solo side it's really usually triggered
by downtime in the work tasks or
distractions like something else
happening on the screen waiting for test
runs waiting for builds i'm sure you
guys all have experience with that the
longer down times will be developers to
assume a secondary task will start doing
something else but once they do it's
really hard for them to switch between
that first and second task they'll have
a build round of running in the
background let's start working on
another bug or documentation that window
covers the build window they don't start
to see it they forget to check it that
leads to really long delays and when
they go back to that first task so
here's kind of an example with Henry
what he's doing is he's finishing up
fixing a bug and he says okay now I'm
just going to run the whole test suite
dr test and see what else breaks see if
that fix you know is doing it so he
starts to run them that's a five-minute
process and as he does so he starts like
at the lowly window he gets a message
from froze about a bug so even though he
says he doesn't want to look at it he
starts reading all the conversation on
Lily to try to get up to speed on that
bug as he's doing so he realizes there's
something in email he wanted to check so
he goes to his email starts writing an
email to someone in the middle of his
email response this is probably like 10
or 15 minutes after that test run was
started everyone else comes and like hey
guys let's go to lunch now so he takes
off for lunch and so that test run he
never texted again until well after he
gets back from lunch so you see
something that five minute process on
the XP team someone would just like SAT
there and watched it and immediately
done that here you get so drawn into a
secondary task that he doesn't come back
to it for over an hour in this case so
tasks easy yeah I mean we saw people do
that a lot they were just kind of like
fragmented get distracted John two
things I mean breaks would trigger
self-insurance initiate interruptions
frequently triggered other ones and so
you saw these long sessions of people
just getting drawn into other stuff
watching videos checking emails her from
the web and then oh right you know my
build was running ya know its talents is
a set of small interruptions here okay
so why did interruptions differ we kind
of talked a little bit about this in
your questions but the kind of four
broad postulates about why so
programmers may have felt a stronger
sense of social obligation to their
partners make any time you have people
working together closely that they tend
to develop this sense of mutual
obligation I think that's really at work
here where people shorten their own
break time sworn those interruptions and
shut them down so they can get back to
working for their partner with their
partner something that you were talking
about it there the pair partners seem to
serve as a cue when people came back to
their task they make that interrupted
task more salient so when you come back
from an intrusion your partner's right
there he or she is working on that task
it's hard for you to get drawn into
another task it's hard for you to
suddenly go in and surf you know the web
because they're right there and they're
working on it to its its immediate that
you see that also they might serve as a
richer and more interactive means for
them to recover state but you don't have
to reconstruct it all in your own based
on what the application presents to you
have someone that you can ask questions
of or more frequently what happens is
the partner will automatically volunteer
an update like we're looking at this now
you know duda that immediately drawn
your attention to that part of the the
code and then you know BAM you're back
and you're back into the task you're not
you don't tend to like wander off into
other their tasks again that's when i
suspect i would love to look at a little
bit more closely with better data but we
didn't have video data that one pair
programmer actions were visible to the
entire team like both the interrupted
pairs their partner and the larger team
at large marketing work and so they had
this immediate sense of accountability
to the whole team that the solo
programmers just didn't have because
they were working in a more isolated
space
and so this meant that like for instance
if you were holding up someone right you
felt you could see that in the context
of the team effort that you are holding
up someone's work you need that
information or if you're interrupting
someone you can also see that more in
the broader team context than if you're
solo and then pair work one thing we
thought was being social seemed to
reduce the need for explicit social
interaction so again those social
interruptions are very short they're
constantly engaged in social interaction
because they need to talk to people
interact with people as a matter of fact
part of their work that's how they get
the job done when they're doing pair
programming so we saw very little them
walking over just to have social
conversations one thing that really
supports this in this data is that the
need for social interaction varies by
person and so and the pair's it was very
uniform everyone had fairly short you
know social numbers of social
interruptions that they engaged in with
other people on the solo site is very
greatly like some people were constantly
talking to other people constantly
talking Oh Lilian some people really
weren't so this is some evidence that it
seems like working in pairs really
serves that need for them and so reduces
the need for you to go out and actually
just start conversations outside of that
okay so some broader conclusions are
mostly looking in terms of how we can
use this for technologies and other
tools to support both parents will work
one really thing that I've been hitting
throughout the presentation that people
really interrupt themselves not
something that hasn't always been
considered when people design support
for interruptive systems usually think
of things as being an external intrusion
but here there's all sorts of ways in
which people get drawn away from their
task and then need to need help being
brought back into that so that's
something that people should really
consider when they're designing work
systems that having contextual
information about the interrupter really
seems to help the person being
interrupted right so giving them easily
processed easily accessible and ideally
independent contextual information about
why the person is coming to interrupt
you can help you make a judgment of that
relative urgency to what you're doing
now and help you design some strategy
for handling it so to minimize the
negative
act-on you see you know this seems to
reduce some stress and some anxiety
about the interruptions that occur
information about ongoing task seems to
help so lending is the solo programmers
soon like that would really benefit from
it some way to monitor the state of
multiple tasks across at the same time
and this is tricky because there's task
span several applications different you
know types of systems and so you know
building into one application is not
necessarily that helpful you need a
solution that cuts across several
applications that can handle some
generalized awareness across task giving
interrupt ease control over interrupt
and duration and end seemed to help so
designing interactions that allow
interrupt is to end interruptions
gracefully or giving some mechanism may
be technically that allows them to
leverage that like more obvious like
okay we need to help them send that
signal a week I need I want to get back
to work now make that really clear
seemed like that might have helped them
and also toss aliens and interactive
QC's task resumption so how can we build
that into an application how can an
application help you come back and
remember where you were in the course of
doing work to get you back to speed and
in thinking about that desk okay and
then finally like any pair programming
differs in some pretty important ways
from solo programming right the pair's
interrupt reacted to interruptions very
differently and that pair work really
seemed to attenuate some of the negative
effects of interruptions and so when we
build tools and technology to be usually
have a solo program in mind so we need
to realize that when things happen in
pairs they don't react the same way and
that's something to consider when we're
constructing these tools and
technologies and that's it questions
comments yes
about open space but non-acidic pair
programming so yeah solo programmers in
an open space oh so we get it seems like
we get some of the benefits like the
awareness of what we're doing and that
people're so morning how much of the
benefits when you say the pair benefits
those are really open how much it is an
open space one yeah that's we tried our
best to tease them apart so when I say
pair I think it's mostly a pair thing
and I tried to attribute to visibility
and that which is you know a function
that shared space when I could but in
this study it's sort of fundamentally
tied together right we have because
that's the nature of our site pair
programmers within an open space so I'd
love to get pair of programmers and
cubicles and see what they do but people
were in cubicles and not in offices but
in closed doors yes social awareness
that you can have yes yeah so you have
slight you have more stuff when you're
in office like we did a look at part of
another study we looked at how people
handle availability and offices and like
they use doors to signal when they want
people to come in and prettier you know
effective ways it's like open come in
and close behind and people in those
studies waited a lot longer to interrupt
like they would go three or four hours
without getting whatever information
they needed they try to send email but
often it just wouldn't come back or it
would come back so delayed it wasn't
useful so that's one difference that you
would have in an office environment
versus this environment cubicles had no
doors so the default assumption is if
you're in work you're accessible which
is probably why we saw people go home
regularly yeah have you looked at
the continuity of the the differences
between solo and pears in terms of
threes or fours or fives on how long
does it take for the solo dynamic starts
coming back borning mean by three or
four I mean have you look at the the
relationship between pairs or threes or
four or five what their similarity along
those lines how long if so how long does
it take before like triplets Oh before
it turns into a small team um we saw no
triplets in the field we did talk to a
group of students that like to work as
triplets but they had a pretty set task
breakdown make the pair's were two
people from the computer talking it out
the triplets they had two people from
computer talking about a third guy who
was like the reference guy on a
different computer and that's what they
called triplet programming but I've
never actually seen it in in the
professional programmer so it's hard for
me to say i would guess based on the
behavior of pairs like pears will get
disengaged sometimes and we actually
looked at another site where they only
had one keyboard and that seemed to make
a pretty big difference in the level
engagement that people had whether or
not you could input in any given minute
they reported being a lot more
disengaged well a lot more they made
comments that indicated that they seem
to be more disengaged in the task you
tended to have one person more
monopolizing the activity there so it
seems like if you have too many people
and they can't have equal kind of access
to the machine then they start to get
disengaged and then become they start to
act more like solo programmers but I
have no data to talk to that yeah
described in terms of the driver you
make any observations about the
navigators of the relationship between
self interruptions and whether on the
driver of the navigator we started to
look at that and what we really found
was it was actually really hard to
distinguish who is the navigator and who
was the driver when they had two
keyboards they were switching a lot
really fast you know and so the
distinction seemed a little meaningless
you didn't have one person sitting here
going let's do this let's do this let's
do this and the other guy kind of
reviewing it was very collaborative and
back and forth no they weren't yeah the
single keyboard team was a little bit
more like that but we didn't look at
interruptions for that so yeah two teams
are working a different types of
applications and other piece of am
getting a very different fantasies from
them to ever feel how those different
dependencies to translate into the
results that you have presented I don't
know necessarily about dependencies what
I could say is that project structure
seem to have a difference maybe that's
what you mean how work was assigned so
the pair's switched and they were sort
of expertise agnostic in terms of how
they assigned their tasks right so you
ad hoc every morning you form a pair and
you work on something if the task last
more than one day then usually you had
one person that had worked on it the day
before but you could be a UI guy and I
mean they're all kind of generalists
right you can be you I guy and you could
be assigned to like doing you know the
XML processing part versus the solos had
very you know this was year you worked
on this part of the project that's yours
you do it you know until you check in
but everyone reviews everyone else's
code on the other hand because it was a
startup company the solo team so those
guys got switched around on projects a
lot and they split their task
assignments a lot like they would hand
things off if another project you know
client had come in
for this sort of improvement well they
only have like 12 programmers if
someone's going to have to be taken off
one pass to do that and someone has to
take up the slack so you saw a similar
sort of shift I was not allowed access
to their code base so i couldn't kind of
get that any deeper which is a shame
maybe something you could do here but so
it seemed like the dependencies could be
roughly equated but I really didn't have
enough of a good look to say you know
whether I saw any big differences coming
out of that didn't seem like it because
the structure of the two teams yeah yeah
um in some sense i mean the star company
had two teams and one of them was the
pair team that was a science project any
other was slowly which handled
everything else and so the whole team
handled everything else um so i don't
know that they necessarily thought of
them as this project team and my time is
getting taken away for this other
project as much as like all of our
developers are responsible for all of
our products and that's kind of part of
the mix seems like there may be work
here
I think what the reason we didn't see
that too much is because when we asked
them to define their primary task we
didn't ask them which project it was on
I mean we could tell from what it was
right so they would have different tasks
for different projects each day but for
that day for like three hours they were
like I'm working on this for this
product so that that's why it doesn't
come out in here yeah
I was not able to get a Productivity
measure they wouldn't let me near the
code so at least in terms of lines all i
had was anecdotal evidence where the
leads told us that or the the vp told us
that the pair team produced code at a
phenomenal rate they were like something
that we've just never seen anything like
this before that they just work so it
was by the time of our second
observation they were actually going
back and making modifications to the
existing code because it had been their
second version release and so it wasn't
all new code the first time it was
almost all new code but they did say
either way they just made changes and
produce good at a phenomenal rate
relative but I don't have anything
quantitative to to show you other than
that statement yeah we didn't see that
sandwich because teen pair was very
isolated since they weren't on Lily they
didn't have connection to the rest of
the company basically all interruptions
from their sanity came through their
lead who would then stand up and
announce it so it took the form of it
within team interruption on that side on
the solo side the whole company was on
Lily so they'd come in through Lily
sometimes and you have people show up I
didn't make a particular effort to
distinguish between that because they
were so few that came from external
sources that it didn't seem worth it
basically yeah so you said with both of
them you got to observe them for many
different phases of development yeah so
did you see any interesting differences
in interruption behavior
in the different phases before release
people showed up more on the suicide at
your door we saw that so there was I
don't want to say that the paceman
interruption but it was highly dependent
on who it was so yes but the data set
might be too small to really pull that
out there were a couple and there was
twice where both teams were waiting for
one person / one pair to check something
in so they can hand the product off and
in that case yeah you saw people showed
up all time that was like what's up
what's the deal you know is it ready yet
but that was sort of one case you didn't
see it so much it wasn't an extended
pattern so again it might have been
there but we didn't have enough to
really look carefully at that yeah the
common argument in favor of private
offices and the concept of flow and it
takes time to get in the flow Mary's do
not doubt in this study did you see any
evidence of that phenomenon didn't help
I want to take
um what was interesting it's kind of a
weirdly defined concept right there's no
real way to say like when is someone in
a flow from watching people people
interrupt themselves so often right i
mean that's why I when I read the
footstep I think like this isn't really
how I see solo developers work so that
was a little strange to me and then in
the pair's there just wasn't that sense
at all of a ramp up like they were like
within a couple seconds they would just
come back immediately be running ahead
at full speed and so that's why I made
me a little more skeptical about the
full of stuff I'll say like especially
because people seriously what all the
time to stop in the course at work and
then pick it back up so it really didn't
seem like there was this 15-minute
20-minute lead time you need it before
you got really productive yeah two teams
or even soloists in the paragraphs
because the pair guys were so isolated
and detached in their own little world
yeah um the solo guy thought the care
guys were dumb the parallel you guys
thought the solo guys are dumb so that's
kind of how that one worked out but yet
I mean it's a startup company right so
it's a pretty small place even if
they're relatively isolated towards that
they have to work pretty closely and
it's their best interest to help the
other guy go along so despite this they
would actually be very helpful when
someone came to ask you questions
and those two they're going to have to
choose one side or the other I think the
solo guys basically saw the pair team is
needing to prove themselves because they
were the new team like slow guys were
there longer and so when an established
product went out then they would make
their judgment is kind of how it seemed
like it was going to go so yeah why was
the company set up like that because the
first time they tried to do the pair's
team's project it was a huge disaster
well I'm actually spent a year and a
half developing for that and scrap the
whole thing and so they said maybe we
need something else and someone said
won't you try this XP thing and so they
came in actually they kind of tried
scrum first but like management hated it
so they kind of like hijack the whole
thing which is why they think they're
doing is from but it's not but then they
brought in this actual team specifically
to do XP with different people and then
they really stuck with it on this one so
that's why you end up with that weird
one because they were at this point
willing to try anything that would sort
of tame that particular projects
development process
they did know each other and that's one
reason it was hardly people usually ask
me personality questions about these
systems it's hard to really say in this
sense because the pair teams were like
specialists in XP it's a small pool of
programmers that that really like XP and
really know a lot about it and when in
bandar lies it so they did know each
other and they brought in a few new
people that didn't so much they kind of
like can tried to convert is what they
say it really seems like a kind of a
cult thing bringing him in but they did
know each other and they had worked
together before so yeah again I couldn't
see the code so it's hard for me to make
that judgment and I'm just watching them
code from behind them so even though you
know I can see the functions it's hard
for me to be like oh that's obviously a
bug you know your relational databases
were like that at all like no i don't i
don't know what i did see is that the
sense what i did pick up is over time
the XP team seemed to think that their
code base was messier because they were
going so fast and the way they had
structured it was so much was going on
that it kind of lost control of how it
was structured overall but i think
that's more of an XP thing you talk
about that a little bit more if you like
I think it's a result of the way they
switch up airs every single time so they
kind of get a loss here and lossy or
concept of what code is supposed to be
whatever task is supposed to be over
time versus the waterfall guys have one
person and then when they check in
everyone on the team reads that check in
so they actually knew that pretty high
fidelity of impression of what that
product code should look like and they
were will take it keep it more cohesive
technically so but I don't think that's
a pair programming thing necessarily
yeah
by us the results been brought in gurus
with XP did they have any equivalent
gurus on the waterfall side no they did
have a central architect and the XP side
even though they weren't supposed to
sort of by the end of the project they
had one guy that that was making calling
the shots on how that was he told me
between you and me don't put this in a
paper but I basically become the central
architecture you know side of architect
for this for this project just like
totally anathema to like XP you know
credo so he didn't want it published but
that's that's what I'm not happening on
lighting in order to keep a lid on that
project oh yeah they're interruptions or
reveal any of your data recorded about
their interruption I have not yet done
that i sent it to my send a previous
paper to it but then they got really
busy and switch management so they kind
of stopped caring about my favorites
when i sent it to them but i didn't ask
him expose leave the XP guys did talk to
me a little bit more about their work
process in terms of they felt that they
should be on target all the time at work
on on top you know and task every time
and the waterfall guys made a couple
comments for the sorry the team slow
guys made a couple comments that were
just like well you know it's okay for us
to goof off a lot because we're working
all the time you know we work from home
all the time and that was sort of their
mindset about it and that seems pretty
universally shared across the team so I
didn't really ask them into have
questions about that yes
most of the facts
looking at the social the people i
thought the fact that the parents had
shorter interruptions are actually
pretty counterintuitive when i initially
encountered it you know I thought there
in this big environment they have more
of an opportunity to talk to people it
seems like you know like you could
imagine in the case where the teams just
start goofing off a lot because
everyone's right there so that for me
was actually counterintuitive to see
that and then looking into why the fact
that where people walk back and forth I
thought it was pretty cool but more
broadly I had some other stuff but not
strictly related to to this stuff that I
thought was very counterintuitive mostly
the the codebase getting Messier and
that information on the XP team seemed
blah seer like everyone knew it right
away when you said something but two
weeks later they'd forget what design
discussion had gone into a particular
decision and you'd hear people asking
about it because they couldn't remember
where's on the waterfall side that stuff
was much more recorded it was with the
same person so they knew that and I
thought that was a little kind of
counterintuitive but that's not part of
this particular work yeah
team work at home hmm how did the jerk
teen solo worked all the time yeah the
XP team did not XP team came in in the
morning worked until you know well they
stayed a little long right before
release or till seven or so and they
went home and they didn't they didn't
work on it until they came back in the
management's don't have a person any
more productive yes so and I think
that's what impressed them about it is
that they seem to be producing so much
more code within a very compressed time
frame yeah averages look at these
statistical variance between the two
one larger offender
um no I did not calculate that number
but I'll tell you that it isn't all
likelihood the variance is much much
higher on the suicides in the parasite
just just from that I mean you had
people that would really have very long
you know five to eight many
interruptions and some people kept them
all really short so you saw a lot more I
think individual personality kind of
being reflected that way like one of
them i think it's grant who was just
very focused I mean you could like prod
him with a stick and he wouldn't really
notice you know he could filter you out
like I told him to ignore me and he like
really didn't get to the point where I
was like okay I take that back you have
to tell me what you're doing before you
completely ignore me but he was really
able to just cut you out and when he got
interrupted he never you know he didn't
do that same pattern that everyone else
did he came back and then you had people
that were really just kind of I don't
call them offenders but they were just
you know cereal sort of like long social
triggered you know takes a long time to
come back and then everyone else is kind
of in between as a parasite it was much
more uniform
I cannot hear young song within the team
condition because they knew the variance
was sure um I don't think they really
thought about their interruptions that
much to be honest yeah yeah Oh get out
of timeless